And of course, the part that is easy to see is that
this is the shortest possible tour,
so these two here cannot be true.
And also this one here cannot be true
because, after all, this is an approximation,
and it is not guaranteed to give us the optimum solution.
The question now is which one of these two here to choose.
So is it always strictly smaller
or can it be the same?
And the correct answer here is that the length of the shortest tour
can actually also be equal to the length of the tour
output by the algorithm.
It's not guaranteed to be, but it can be.
And this could be the case, for example,
if the input that we are given
is already a tree, then the spanning tree
will just be the input network itself.
Then a shortest tour is indeed a walk along that tree.
So in this case, you would have equality here.
So length of the tour that we compute is at least as large
as the length of the shortest tour but not always strictly bigger.